if I step outside of this apartment I'm
looking at six months in jail
governments have been implementing
lockdowns its ghostly there's nobody out
in asking citizens to self isolate to
fight the corona virus pandemic I'm
really trying to stay indoors as much as
possible
they've enforced these measures using
drones and police to hunt out rogue
pedestrians throwing to murk water to
tag people violating quarantines and in
some countries even putting offenders in
jail there is police everywhere so the
chances of getting stopped are very high
we asked our reporters to document what
life on lockdown looks like in three
cities kind of surprised to see as many
people out it's so strange to see how
people's behavior has changed and found
that some countries are more willing to
enforce stricter measures than others in
order to stop the virus Italy has been
one of the harder hit countries in March
the government imposed a nationwide
lockdown for everyone including our
reporter margarita Stein kadhi
in Rome this is the Pantheon in Rome
there's no one here now there's no one
here relieved to see that people seem to
be keeping to themselves
normally here there would be a dozen or
so people I'd mind the view but today
there is nobody it is just me the
government allows very few exceptions
for people to step outside basically no
one is really allowed out of their house
unless they can prove they really have
to what does that mean people can go out
to go buy groceries to go buy drugs or
if they have a job considered still
essential if they really can't work from
home Hong Kong on the other hand has
adopted a radically different strategy
it has decided to quarantine a very
narrow group of people who could
potentially infect others here's where
I'm spending two weeks of my time it's a
five hundred square foot apartment in
Hong Kong
the Hong Kong government required our
reporter Dan strength to self isolate
for 14 days after he travelled abroad
the city is quarantine anybody that's
coming into Hong Kong regardless of
where they're coming from the city is
also closing itself off to any visitors
who are not residents of Hong Kong
there's also other citywide measures
like gatherings of more than four people
are forbidden movie theaters and gyms
are closed but that aside Hongkongers
are relatively free they can go out and
shop they can still go to restaurants
that are still open meanwhile the u.s.
hasn't imposed a nationwide lockdown
instead many states have issued shelter
and place orders this is the first time
I've left the building in about almost a
week in New York the epicenter in the
u.s. one of our editors Daniela
Hernandez has been living in a system
that may sound drastic this is not life
as usual we've taken every action that
government can take remain indoors to
the greatest extent but towards the end
of March that didn't appear to be the
case on the ground here in Central Park
same problem has arisen in California
where people have been going on hikes
many people don't hesitate for a second
to head outside even if it means
standing in line next to others
way around the block just how crowded
the streets are comes down to how
difficult the government makes it for
people to leave their homes I can't even
go out to get groceries and I'm totally
reliant on my friends to make deliveries
to my apartment Hong Kong decided to
tightly control people in quarantine
using high-tech surveillance equipment
so the government's keeping back of
anybody in quarantine by slapping a
wristband on them there's a serial
number on the wristband that's assigned
to me as well as a QR code the second
element to the quarantine is an app on
my phone the app actually pairs up with
the bracelet that allows Hong Kong
authorities to keep track of exactly
where I am if I do leave my home the app
on my phone makes a loud noise and
authorities are alerted within and out
so Hong Kong was hit very hard by the
SARS epidemic back in 2002 in 2003 and
as a result of the lessons from from
that particular time the city's been
very bold in taking aggressive measures
to contain the virus this time and the
population has been listening to the
government in Rome as well as in Paris
in other European cities there are no
hi-tech devices like in Hong Kong it's
actually the opposite the government has
gone fully analogue the thinking behind
the forms is twofold
on one hand it's really sending a
message that this is serious you can't
just go out within any excuse you have
to think about why you're going out and
you have to be able to prove it in New
York the government put faith in
people's self-discipline but soon
realized it needed to become stricter as
a number of cases and deaths rose in New
York the governor recently announced
that he was going to increase the fine
for not social
from $500 to a thousand people weren't
really apparently but new york's
consequences are not as severe compared
to other regions if you are found
leaving the house although you're
supposed to be on the quarantine because
of your you can your health condition
then you actually could face jail time
hong kong the penalty ranges up to six
months in prison and a twenty five
thousand Hong Kong dollar fine which
amounts to about three thousand five
hundred US dollars or so the most
draconian lockdown was in China's Hubei
Province where the pandemic first
emerged the w-h-o says intense policing
and surveillance networks helped contain
the spread of the virus
but those measures were extreme and most
unlikely to work in much of the world
for these kinds of draconian measures to
be imposed on a Western democracy is
absolutely shocking people could not
believe what was happening but as the
pandemic is progressing more european
countries and US states are replicating
some of the strict measures seen in
italy and even China although it seems
unthinkable when all this started
by and large people have understood why
these restrictions are necessary because
it infections are just simply out of
control but who knows how long they're
gonna put up with it